all right what is your opinion of
Gnosticism I think I've talked about
this before I think one of the problems
one of the problems with people who look
at Gnosticism is that okay if you read
the book by st. Irenaeus on Gnosticism
it is actually called I think it's
called something like for the overthrow
for the identification and overthrow of
the so-called Gnostics right and the
reason why they're called so-called
Gnostics is because the notion of gnosis
in Christianity is actually very
important it's a very important it's a
very important aspect of Christianity
the the difference between the Gnostics
and and the traditional gnosis in
Christianity is that gnosis in
Christianity is really in a manner what
I talk about when I talk about symbolism
that is it is gnosis is viewed as a
sexual Union in the Bible right
knowledge like he knew his wife it's not
it's seen as this this coming together
of two realities right and if those who
are reading Matthews book will see it in
that manner - it's that it's the joining
of heaven and earth that's what gnosis
is knowledge is is is the the two coming
together right in in the in the
traditional sense
and so in Christianity that's why we
have this whole incarnation or vision of
the world right Christ is incarnate he
is the total joining of of divinity and
humanity the total joining of meaning
and and in a person everything is joined
together right so that's that's what
gnosis is in in the Christian tradition
where the Gnostics they tended to view
gnosis as this in the platonic sense as
moving out of the cave right the world
of manifestation is actually an illusion
and a kind of lie and you have to you
have to kind of transcend the the
manifestation so that you see the
principles for themselves okay and and
and because of that then their vision of
Christ is that either he was not either
there's a separation between the logos
of God and the human
Jesus right that those two are separate
and that you know the logos of God
leaves Jesus before his crucifixion that
type of thinking or you have this idea
that Christ was a ghostly figure that he
wasn't fully manifested you have these
images like you know it's feet didn't
touch the ground or or these types of
images to say to say that that that that
Christ was not a fully incarnate me okay
whereas in Christianity really is this
notion of incarnation um so I think that
narcissism you know in Turin
Christianity you do have this notion of
transcending you do you do have this
notion of ascending the mountain right
of going up the ladder of principality
let's say moving towards the divine
darkness so removing the garments of
skin all of those images could be seen
as akin to this notion of leaving the
cave let's say but if you look at the
final result of that it's always that in
the end we recover what we had removed
let's say so that as you move into the
divine darkness you find that everything
was joined together you see that in st.
Maximus the Confessor he talks about how
how as the the spiritual person sees the
the lobby sees the spiritual reasons for
things separate from the the
manifestations like the particularities
he sees that there's no contradiction
between the two that they're actually
there they're actually they actually are
in full agreement with each other and so
when Moses enters into the divine
darkness in saint gregory of nyssa he he
encounters the pattern of the tabernacle
and in the pattern of the tabernacle he
finds the garments of skin in the
tabernacle and so he removed his sandals
at the base of the mountain to ascend
the mountain but once he enters into the
highest point then he finds that the
whole mountain you could say that the
whole mountain is actually inside that
point right that that the highest point
of the hierarchy is actually not that
which transcends the hierarchy but that
which contains the whole hierarchy and
that's one of the things maybe that's
kind of different between what I think
in andorran Peterson we we've actually
talked about this in I think even online
talk about this how Christ it's not that
Christ transcends the hierarchy it's
that Christ fills the hierarchy and so
the image of Christ is is is not of the
this just the image of the the the
Emperor or the image of the highly
successful you know person he's and and
and even he's not just the image of the
person who accepts suffering but he's
also an image of a criminal being being
crucified so he's both the judge you
know of all things he's the he's the son
of man he's all this glorious has all
this glorious imagery but at the same
time he is the the crucified criminal
outside the city right and you see it
like and you see it and you can see it
in the opposition in the story where
Christ goes into the temple clears out
the temple right acts as this holy
scourging fire which purifies everything
but then he's taken outside the city and
he's crucified so it's like bang those
two those two radical opposites just
jammed together and and Christ always
manifests that fullness of the hierarchy
where he's both the top of the hierarchy
and the bottom of the hierarchy at the
same time right and then he says right
that he says the Alpha and the Omega
right I am the beginning in the end and
he also says that those two things are
related to each other that there's a
connection between the beginning and the
end right you know you see it in that
snake eating its tail